he is oh and one on the season with a 6
46 earned run average but two starts ago
he had a terrific outing five innings no
walks nine
strikeouts against the boston red sox in
that doubleheader
fastball high ball four no surprise the
keen eye of cavan vigil seeing a lot of
pitches in his first hit bat
two on one out loudest guriel junior the
batter
miss he got him with a slider strikeout
number one
for vince two outs here in the first
one two on the way swinging a miss
struck him out
and that'll do it for the jays no runs
on one hit
hunjin ryu will make his 11th start of
the season his numbers are respectable
across the board
just 14 walks in 54 innings and 60
strikeouts
he's got the sign he deals with a
curveball swing and a miss by sagura
who tumbles in the right-handed batters
box and he got him to chase this curve
are you ready with the runner at first
in the pitch a curveball swing and a
miss by gregorius
he's down on strikes and back-to-back
punch-outs for hingin ryu
lead-off walk to start in the second
that'll bring up vr 3-2 rudder goes
pitch
loops off the third base line sigour
what a play
sprawling to the ground he hung on
that was a man on a mission right there
how far did he have to run to get to
this baseball
my goodness he had to go a long way
rudder goes
pitches hit in the air off the right
side
gosselin sprints in so is napping that
makes the catch
pulled it right out out of the air how
to bring up jay bruce
j bruce who was activated yesterday
started at first base
curveball and he strikes out another one
three strikeouts already for ryu
now he threw 15 pitches in the first
inning 10 of those pitches were
fastballs either cutters or four
seam fastballs the 3-2 swing and a miss
at a breaking ball down to the dirt
quick tag applied by jansen
the strikeout completes a one two three
second inning of work for hinge and
reader
let's see if the blue jay's gonna make
him pay gotta do some damage eventually
with all the free passes they're getting
ground ball to short stop that could be
two gregorius the second for one kingry
back over to first in time
six four three double play and that's a
big one right there to put two outs on
the board
swinging and miss velasquez gets through
this third and he picks up his third
strikeout
of the night three strikeouts three
walks for vinnie andrew knapp will start
it off
302 average for nap flight drive out to
left field that'll be in for a base hit
all you got to do is ask tom right first
hit of the night for the fills andrew
knapp and strike three called and
mccutcheon thought that ball was outside
but it's the fifth strike out of the
night for ryu swinging to miss got him
with a change up down and in
for strikeout number six on the night
for hinging
for seven against vince in his career
swing and a miss
that's a heck of a battle won by
velasquez four strikeouts for vince
the 1-0 shaw hits it hard high in the
air out to deep right field
harper gets back to the wall turns
around goodbye
travis shaw takes one into the seats
above the wall and right field
travis shaw makes it one nothing blue
jays so andrew knapp
with the opportunity here runner in
third less than two out
the ball is lined into left field to
base it for andrew knapp
his second of the night it'll bring home
bruce when the phillies have tied this
game up it won
first and third with one out back toward
the middle
and into center field another base hit
andrew knapp scores rbi single for
mccutcheon
and the phillies have taken the lead
faces are now
loaded curveball and a swing and a miss
in a big second out you got segura on a
curveball in the first
inning and looked like almost the
identical pitch and he swings
over the top of it once again the pitch
gregorio swings and he lines the ball to
the gap in the left center field guriel
hustles over to his left he's there
making the catch to retire gregorius and
the side but the phillies get eight into
the plate
lake parker will take over for the
phillies
fly ball shallow left segura is there
two gone lower than low here
he tried to check did he go yes he did
says ramon dejesus
and the blue jays for a second
consecutive inning go
in order nothing across so ryan berecki
will be asked to face bryce harper with
one out
and two runners on 2-2 as a slider
hitting the air out to right field on
the move biggio goes into a slide
makes the catch that played it halfway
between second and third
ensuring that he would score if it
dropped in the o2
pounding ball out in front of the mound
fielded by burucky
underhand feet over to shaw to retire
segura and the phillies
and ryan berecki gets around the two
walks by wilmer font and he keeps the
phillies off the scoreboard in the
seventh
load the bases for andrew knapp one two
swing and a miss got him to chase two
down get that big two out knock here
that one's hit over toward the left side
but shet makes a diving play from a
knees not gonna make a play
and adam haisley drives in an insurance
run it's three to one
but there are two outs here in the ninth
inning and a cold strike three
three scoreless hittings for the
phillies bullpen
right on top of vince velasquez his six
solid innings tonight